Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and me and my family we're here
in the deserts of Nevada and we're four
by fouring and camping and exploring and
having a great time isn't that right
guys yeah yeah
I'm the gingerbread man
[Music]
hey guys check it out there's like a
mine shaft on the side of the road
well I think someone's been used in this
place as a toilet
they mine Brown gold in there
all right guys welcome to Nevada
we are in the moabi desert this is the
largest desert in North America
the cactus
the most exciting thing I have seen out
here was a flat tire and a hot radiator
there's like a little historical marker
that says that sign was put up by
someone named pyramid Bob who would
commune with aliens
you cow been abducted CNA aliens
moo take me to your leader
oh
I just wrote I think that that comes
from that plant
it's a piece of cactus wood
check it out that's a Joshua Tree where
the streets have no name
foreign
we're just driving down this wash we see
these petroglyphs up there it's like a
little lizard and a man and some other
things you guys want to ride in the bed
foreign
rock formation called little Finland all
right guys you ready to keep going
exploring yeah all right let's do it
[Music]
foreign
guys I think this is it
[Music]
so we're looking for seven Keyhole Slot
Canyon we're gonna go try to check that
out should be somewhere in this rock
formation
look at what the Rocks there might be
some petroglyphs up here see right up
there there's just a little patch of
them right there in the dark stuff
lots of petroglyphs right in here look
at that
so this is seven Keyhole Slot Canyon
check it out
so apparently there's seven Keels can
you guys find all seven there's two
right there
actually
three four five
[Music]
look at this is this cool
this is kind of cool babe are you glad
we did this
what do you think babe is this cool it's
very cool kind of one of the few chances
to go check out a Slot Canyon without
tons of people around and it's right by
the road yeah it's nice it's nice
no
Petroglyph right there oh yeah
oh yeah look someone did a little foot
there
oh over here look at this
something
yeah you can see there's scratch like a
bird's foot right there I wonder what's
down this dark cave
terrifying did I get this
look there's ferns in the desert oh look
at that
it sounds kind of moist I bet there's
like water or spring or something in
here
for the wall right there you can see
this this looks like a bug
[Music]
yeah I don't know what I don't know what
that is
[Music]
you saw Japanese words
oh that's a human right there
oh yeah yeah that's pretty it is a
flower I can see I could see it yeah
thousands of years ago bored teenagers
graffitied this cave now it's history
and art
oh look at that it's a bird nest I've
been trying
oh
there's the entrance
it ain't hot yeah it is a nice little
Hut
foreign
[Music]
I got The High Ground
well guys should we get back to the car
before it gets dark and we lose the path
we don't want to get lost in the desert
it's hard to see but there's a canyon
behind that big rock and another Canyon
over there I think we could spend days
exploring this and have a great time
doing it
good job
what do you think Tom I think this might
be a decent camps fight
you guys watch out I'm gonna back the
truck up
all right
let's pull those rocks out make a fire
pit
here Tom
will you help with the wood
okay Jacob you ready for a job
I need you to pick up dead wood see all
those little sticks go pick up as many
sticks as you can and fill up the fire
pit with sticks grab any dead sticks you
see and put them in the fireplace
foreign
there you go here I got my knife I undo
all the plastic on all of this wood
just be really careful make sure no
one's around you
there you go there's Jacob's bag
all right
we got these little Zips lighter blocks
I love these things
yeah I know
what do you think Bob is this nice it's
very nice
[Music]
yeah you like my puffy fans
oh good
all right guys what do you want first
hot apple cider or grilled cheese
sandwiches and soup okay
I'll get dinner going first
I may I
come out
that's it
all right there we go got some hot water
boiling on my stove we got some
briquettes kind of going so I'm gonna
start cooking off those a nice campfire
keep everybody cozy
come on
kind of hold it like this
let me go
really good temperature
cut it like that there you go so let's
start laying down pieces of bread
try to get one that matches in size
let's see this plot was a bit hot oh
that's already getting toasty
stage real quick
foreign
all right I'm heating up some chicken
noodle soup I'm cooking grilled cheese
sandwiches we're gonna have a good
dinner tonight oh these are perfect
okay grab a plate grab there's a big
pile
please put it on a plate okay
we got bowls for soup
okay you ready
there you go here throw another Bowl in
there so it's a little stronger
are you ready
you got that
there you go there's a nice big ball
that cup right there
what do you think you like the grilled
cheese sandwich and soup
pretty good huh Tom you like the
sandwich
gonna make it worth going camping with
me
all right let's get you some soup okay
Becca you look adorable eating that
you're sweet
so good and nice and warm that is a good
grilled cheese sandwich right there
dipped out in chicken noodle soup you
can't beat it
Makita grilled cheese sandwich lots of
butter lots of cheese
what you got there babe
Madeline dipped in hot apple cider and
it looks so good
Madeline
and make sure you want to eat plenty of
food so you have energy for stay warm
oh that's good
that's why did you grab a marshmallow
stick okay check this out
mallolicious strawberry marshmallows
calories don't count on campouts
hey Jacob you want a marshmallow there
are strawberry flavored marshmallow
that's straight shaped like a strawberry
hey
oh now mine's on fire oh you hear that
crunch on that shell you like that
Nathan purple marshmallow I think you
like that that's so good you want a
sword Jake
okay we're gonna put a marshmallow stick
in a cup
there you go
there's your there's your fencing foil
that's what
Three Musketeers
we gotta get you guys ready for bed
there you go right there in the chest
rubbed off
I found this at the store and I bought
it for Becca it's a laugh warmer lasts
up to eight hours and the thing weighs
about a pound it's like the equivalent
of like 10 hand warmers so I'm gonna
throw this in her sleeping bag tonight
all right guys here's our sleeping
Arrangements we've got the four man tent
which barely fits three mats me Becca
and Jacob are gonna sleep in there and
then we're gonna have Tom and Nate here
in the pickup truck they're gonna lay
down on the bench seats Tom's got the
back seat and we got Nathan in the front
seat it's not that cold tonight it's
cold
please but I think everybody will be
warm tonight I think I think we'll keep
everybody more toasty are you gonna get
on out in there there you go
he got a toe warmer on your butt
yeah keep your crack orb
s
just sitting here brushing my teeth I
can see a little kangaroo rat or
something peeking out at us see the long
long tail oh aren't they cute they're so
fluffy
yeah look there he is winning a little
bro over there those things are really
cute they're just little puff balls with
these super long tails and these big
hind legs they just could go
I got two liters of boiling water here
we're gonna put this in Becca's bag
inside your sleeping bag
there you go put it put it inside your
sleeping bag
are you warm in there
okay
you're like a trapdoor spider
so you're plenty warm okay you good
all right buddy I'll see you in the
morning
that water bottle helping out yeah
okay
all right guys buddy I'll see you in the
morning okay
all right good night bud mind your head
oh me and Becca got the kids to bed and
it's a couple hours before our bedtime
and we're just hanging out here by the
fire listening to audiobooks and
chatting and it's just a wonderful night
I'm just grateful it's not raining and
it's above freezing those are just two
big things for me I'm just glad that we
got that
all right thank you is it time for the
massive hand warmer
hold everybody
it's enormous oh I'm so excited all
right I just say put that in your
sleeping bag babe and uh that should be
nice and toasty in about 30 minutes 20
minutes and that'll keep you warm I
think should we go hit the SAG sure
let's do it
it's cute
well we've talked back in we're gonna
see if she can survive the night I'm
gonna put the camera up and we're gonna
see you guys in the morning
it was warm all night
I did not sleep well it was very windy
and rainy and stormy about an hour and a
half after we went to bed this wind and
rainstorm came in and it just about
flattened the tent I think it was like
is the tech gonna blow away and I'm like
man baby you know very helpful husband
response I heard the lid do our pot get
blown through the air and down the hill
get up and start getting some breakfast
babe
foreign
Jacob awake
yeah see how the boys are doing
are you okay
oh boys are alive and well
everything
well everything is soaking wet that's
okay
all right got a hot water for a cider
all right we got a great breakfast plan
they got a sweet brioche loaf that I'm
going to turn into French toast
we've got whipped cream and blueberries
and syrup I also got bacon eggs hot
apple cider muffins and madeleines
no one's going hungry today
yeah that's a good looking bacon there
okay
Becca's getting out of the tent got to
get her hot apple cider ready
good morning Mama do you like a plate
and some hot apple cider
here's Mama's plate oh my goodness
that's beautiful here's here's some
Cutlery and there is your hot apple
cider I poured a little while ago so it
might be getting close to the right temp
oh thank you that's gorgeous mama
that's amazing
why don't you guys come out there's
french toast and bacon waiting for
everybody
blueberries don't you maple syrup well I
don't mind if we do right whipped cream
there we go
why I think it's okay
we're just about finishing up breakfast
and uh it's starting to rain on us again
we've been traveling the Southwest for
eight days now and all but one of those
days we have been snowed on or rained on
all these rumors you hear about the
desert being hot and dry completely fall
very wet and cold yeah like a dick knows
how to stay dry look at that
oh
everything's soaking wet so we're gonna
have to hang it up to dry anyways when
we get home so no point in putting it
away nicely
thank you
well babe what'd you think this was
great you rocked it thanks you stayed
warm I was really warm and you got good
food I got great food and it's beautiful
and even with the rain it's pretty look
at this well I think we better get in
the car because we've got a long way to
4x4 and we've got to go to Las Vegas so
Becca can destroy a car with a backhoe
it's on the to-do list today he's on the
to-do list
Rebecca what did you think of your hot
hands thing I love that this thing is
still warm look at the size of this
thing
wow yeah well that's pretty luxurious
there
that was a crazy fun campsite I like
this winter desert camping stuff
well looks like we made it back to
civilization
Liz if you guys enjoyed this video as
much as we enjoyed camping today make
sure to click subscribe to the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel we put out new
videos every Saturday morning and if you
want to see our entire nine-day trip
across the Southwest U.S make sure to
check out the link in the video
description below got that video as well
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
next Saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]